OK, so how do we figure this out?
>> Cleverly, so I, when I, when I see things
like this, I just like to be methodical, so why don't
we just be methodical so, I'm going to ask the question
whether the vc dimension is at least one, because it's pretty
easy to think about and maybe I'll get a feel
for how to get the right answer that way. OK, so
is the vs dimension at least one? Well, the answer
is pretty clearly yes, so if you just put a dot
on the number line somewhere. You could, yeah like that. You could
label it positive just by picking any a less than or equal
to that point and any b greater than or equal to that
point. So, if, if I were like drawing parentheses or something to
indicate the interval, I could just put parenthesis around the point and
that will give me a plus or brackets, that would be fine.
Okay, so that's that's pretty easy. And if I wanted it to
be negative, I could just put both of the brackets on either
side of the point, it doesn't matter, let's say to the left.
Alright, that make sense Michael?
>> That's exactly what I was thinking about, yeah.
Though I would've put the brackets on the right.
>> Yeah, you would. okay, so then
we could see...do the same argument for, see
if the VC dimension is greater than or equal to two. So if I put two
points on the line, so there are
only,there're four possibilities I gotta get. Plus plus,
minus plus, plus minus, and minus minus. Okay,
so we gotta get plus plus, plus minus,
minus plus and minus minus. So, the, the first and the
last one are really easy. Actually they're all easy but you
can definitely do this. So, if you want to get plus
plus, you just need to put brackets so that they surround the
two points, that's good. If you want to get plus minus you
put the left bracket in the same place and you put the
right bracket just to the right of the point, yeah, and
you do the same thing for minus plus and then for minus
minus you put the brackets on either side of both of the points and
so, since you like it to the right I'm going to put em to the left.
>> [LAUGH] Good.
>> And there you go, that was, that was pretty easy I think. Okay so next
we need to figure out whether the VC dimensions at least three. So we need three
dots on a line, three, distinct dots on
a line. And we've got eight possibilities but
Michael I don't want you to write down
those, those eight possiblities because I think I see
an easy way to answer the question right away.
>> Excellent
>> So, this is a lot like the last
example we did with, with the theta. Except now.
>> Yeah.
>> We only have two parameters. And the problem with had with the theta was
that as we moved the theta over, from left to right, we lost the ability
to, to, to have a, a, a positive followed by a, a negative. So I
think there's a similar thing here. So,
if you label those three points this way.
Plus, minus, and plus. I don't, I don't think you can
do that, and that's because in order to get point one
and point three in the interval, you're going to have to put
the brackets on both sides of them. So you're going to have
to put a, a left bracket to the left of the
first point and a right bracket to the right of the
third point. And that's the only way to make those two
plus. But then you're always going to capture the one in the middle.
So you can't actually shatter three points, with this hypothesis class.
>> Now, you have to argue though, that
there isn't some other way you could arrange the
three points. I don't know like, I don't know,
stacking them on top of each other or something.
>> You mean vertically on top of one each other?
>> Yeah.
>> Well then they wouldn't be in R, they'd be in R2.
>> Well no, just like right on top of each other.
>> Well then they're all the same point.
>> And you
can't label them. Again, you have the same problem that you can't label one of
them negative and the other ones positive if they're all on top of each other.
>> Right.
>> So, so there isn't, there just isn't any way to set up
these three points so that you're able to assign them all possible labels.
>> Right.
>> So, good, so that gives us two as our answer here.
So, by the way, I think that you said something I think that's
really important. In order to prove the lower bound, in order to prove
one and two, all we had to do was come up with an
example where we could chatter, right?
>> Yes, that's exactly right.
>> Right, so so that's good and that's
that's really nice because otherwise we're in a
heap of trouble [LAUGH] if we have to
show that you can shatter every single thing. We
just have to show that you can shatter
one thing. So, it exists. So that whole VC
dimension is really a...there exists some set of
points you can shatter, not you can shatter everything.
>> That's right, and what would be an example of points that you couldn't
shatter yeah, a pair of points that you couldn't shatter?
>> Well, the ones on top of one another.
>> Yeah, exactly, because you wouldn't
be able to assign them different labels.
>> Right.
>> So that would be a really bad choice,
and here all we need is a good choice.
>> Right. So, if you make good choices you can
shatter things, which sounds more violent than I intended. Okay
but, in the third case of the VC dimension, it
wasn't enough to show an example that you couldn't shatter, because,
then you could do the same thing as you
point out, with a VC dimension of two. Instead you
have to prove that no example exists. So, there does
not exist or a for all not word or something.
>> For all, not.
>> [LAUGH] Exactly. So, that, that's a, that's an interesting set of set of
requirements there, right? So, proving a lower
bound seems easier than proving an upper bound.
>> Though it's interesting cause in this case, in cases
one and two, you had to show that all the
different combinations were covered, whereas in this last case we
just had to give one combination that couldn't possibly be covered.
>> Yeah, but it couldn't possibly be covered no matter
what we did. No matter what the input arrangement was.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Whereas in the first case, I had to show all possibilities.
I mean, you know, all possible labelings but only for one example
of orderings or one collection of points. So just messily
doing some bad predicate calculus to, nail down what you're saying.
That when we say that the answer is yes, we're
saying that there exists a set of points of a certain
size, since that for all labelings, no matter how we,
we want to label it. There is some hypothesis that works for
that labeling. But to say no, we have to do
the legation of that which is not exist for all exist.
Which, by standard logic rules says that, that means
for all points, no matter how you arrange the
points, it's not the case that for all labels.
There exists hypothesis which again DeMorgan's Law its not against
DeMorgan's Law to to apply this idea that says
that's the same as for all arrangements of points
there's some labeling where there's no hypothesis that's going
to work and that's exactly how you made your argument.
>> Huh, except I didn't use DeMorgan's Law and
upside down a's and backwards z's. Oh you did, oh you did.
>> Hm. I am the [INAUDIBLE] powerful.